the number of coronavirus cases outside
China is growing rapidly in Europe
infections have skyrocketed in Italy
mark Phillips is in cadonia southeast of
Milan mark what's the response there
good morning well this is the limit of
the area of northern Italy affected by
the corona virus outbreak and the
numbers have continued to rise the
Italian Health Ministry says that
overnight there have been more than 50
new cases bringing the total to close to
300 police have cordoned off areas near
Milan and Venice where about 50 thousand
people live but the question is whether
all the cases of the virus reported in
Italy can be traced to this region in
Venice where this is normally carnival
time the party's over
canceled days early the masks have
changed and people are getting out of
town as everywhere the deaths associated
with the virus have affected the most
vulnerable
Luigi de Angelo is coordinating Italy's
emergency response the doctors told us
clearly that the people have been earth
died because they were infected by by
other problems of aged they were already
sick yeah they were already sick and the
coronavirus have amplifies amplified
there they are sick but their sickness
the World Health Organization hasn't
pressed the panic button and has
refrained from calling this a pandemic
this is not an uncontained global spread
they say disease it's still possible to
be contained but if some fail if some do
not do everything that is needed this
can still become out of control with
dramatic consequences in global health
and global economy and stock markets
around the world were nervous after the
big Falls in New York yesterday more
proof if any was needed Tony of the
connection between public health and
economic health Mark Phillips for us in
Italy mark thank you very much